BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
I definitely wasn't confused there for a moment, Ruffians.
What?
Confused?
You didn't notice anything, right?
Huh?
I was caught off guard.
It's okay, I'm good.
Are you weak, Moco-chan?
Yeah, I'm good, I'm good!
BAU BAU!
And today, we're gonna host a FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU, thank you for joining us for our 147th episode!
BAU BAU!
Caught off guard by what?
Is that a misunderstanding?
I wanna know.
I thought the order was different.
I thought... BAU BAU!
Thank you for joining us for our 146th episode!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
Are you using it?
Here's Moco-chan!
I got confused.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
But!
But the Ruffians and I saw Ruffians happy to be able to join us today.
Maybe it's your first time.
Maybe it's not your first time.
Maybe first time for the year.
But for the Ruffians that are, you know, maybe forgot.
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short four-night morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face
Hope you start your day off on the right paw.
So, please take your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Are you awake now?
Okay?
Good.
BAU BAU!
That's not good enough.
We gotta start your day off on the right paw, okay?
BAU BAU!
You're not awake!
What are we gonna do about that, Moco-chan?
However, there has to be a bad part to the day, right, Ruffians?
It'll spook you weak, okay?
This'll be the worst part of the day today.
Okay.
Got it.
Let's get it done with.
Where was Pero Sighted this time?
De-den!
Is this a Pero Sighting?
So nice and comfy.
No more.
Look at the sky.
What the hell is there?
I just wanted to look at the sky, Moco-chan.
Focus on the sky.
Watching the sunrise together with the Ruffians though.
Ruffians!
Why do you like Pero so much?
I don't get it.
It's nasty!
Hi.
Pero Rue.
Why would you choose that Rue?
He's soft.
Aoshi.
Hi.
He's like a circle.
He's cool.
He's round.
He's all muscle.
My love.
Hi.
That's some pretty big words there.
But, uh, Ruffians, you're not waking up early.
You know, Ruffians, you're like, oh, I'm not awake.
You know, it's FUWAMOCO Morning.
If you wanna go see the sunrise, you gotta wake up pretty early.
You couldn't wake up that early to be able to go and hang out with Pero and see the sunrise.
Hi!
Are you here to have FUWAMOCO Morning?
I don't know, Ruffians, that's kind of funny.
Huh?
It's a weird day, but, but, if it was us, Ruffians!
But you wake up early to see the sunrise.
Huh?
Watching the sun rise together with FUWAMOCO.
Are you sure you want to start the day off on the right paw?
I'm gonna do it anyways.
I'm gonna do it.
And then the Ruffians will be like, okay, maybe, maybe I'll watch the sunrise together with FUWAMOCO.
We'll teach you hard!
We're the best sunrise watchers ever!
No, Pero!
BAU BAU!
Speaking of watching things, actually Ruffians, there's something even better than the sunrise to watch right now!
We're happy to share the ice FUWAMOCO with you in the newest episode of hololive!
BAU BAU!
We're super happy and this time we're together with Poruru-oneechan and want to go for a nice spring picnic.
Look at us there.
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Maybe there's some Ruffians wondering what is hologram?
Hologram is a weekly hololive animation show that gets uploaded to the official
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
But you know, we're not gonna tell you what happened.
You can go check it out with your own two eyes on the hololive official YouTube account.
And there's a link on our community page as well.
You know, makes it extra simple.
But you know, hololive is cool and awesome.
But there's something actually a little silly.
Because Moco-chan!
I realize Moco-chan made a little mistake.
Ruffians!
Even my 3D Senpai noticed!
She tweeted about it!
You know... I misread it!
I misread the kanji in the script!
How was I supposed to know, huh?
How else was I supposed to read it?
Okay!
Look!
It says...
Koo-ame.
Koo-ame!
That's how you read the kanji!
It should be Koo-ame!
No, it's not read like that!
How am I supposed to read it if it's Koo-same?
You know!
That's the correct reading.
Koo-same makes me think!
Kousame.
Babyshark.
But it's not babyshark!
Because babyshark is kou-zame.
It becomes zame with a ten-ten.
So then how am I supposed to do this without an S in front of ame so that it becomes kousame?
Hai!
What?
That's it though, if you do check the dictionary, it does say Kouame, but... Kouame wa chigau, yone.
Tsukawanai.
Nobody uses it.
Nante!
Ima kara daijoubu deshou!
Iwakan aru no kana?
Iwakan nai!
Betsu ni kimi nara?
Oh!
En!
Yokotto.
Mococo warukunai.
Daijoubu datte hazu?
It's okay!
Tsukawanai!
Tsukawatte!
Nobody uses it.
So even though the dictionary says yes, if nobody uses it, the dictionary is wrong.
It's now koame.
No Moco-chan, it's kosame.
Now, koame.
You better hope it doesn't drizzle in the future, huh?
Tiny ring.
Yes.
Okay.
And, baby should be kosame.
Because kosame just sounds wrong.
That's all.
BAU BAU!
I'm okay now.
No problems.
Nihongo muzukashii.
Sonna koto nai yo!
Dakedo kore wa machigatteru janai desu ka kore!
BAU BAU!
You with me!
Yeah!
Mococo's always right!
Moco-chan, you can call Abyss from now on and I'll just use this as a warning.
I just wanna say no Moco-chan made a mistake.
I also made an embarrassing mistake.
I called a piece of paper a piece of hair today.
BAU BAU!
Maybe.
Maybe not.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Maybe if you've been taking a little bit of a look at Twitter, you noticed something.
But Subaru-senpai, she put out a very interesting questionnaire.
Yeah?
She's asking for your opinion!
It's important that you answer!
She's asking you, Ruffians!
She wants you to think not too deeply.
Yeah, don't think deeply about it.
Yeah, just simply, you know?
Tell her your true feelings, whatever's on your heart.
Yeah.
What's the question?
What's that?
I... I... What's that?
Question?
Which member of hololive are you?
Could be piano-ya, repeat-ya, idea-ya, voice-ya.
Which member has the strongest form?
But I'm not Mari-sensei-senpai because obviously she's the strongest of them all, right?
Ruffians, did you figure it out?
The strongest what, Moco-chan?
The strongest what?
You have to say it again, the Ruffians didn't hear.
Couldn't hear.
Sighting!
No.
Let's speak up, Moco-chan.
I think the Ruffians understood because they said they voted for Mococo!
Hai!
Couldn't hear soy.
Moco-chan, I think there's some Ruffians that really don't get it.
Hai!
Gonna have to say it again.
Why don't you?
I'm not gonna say it, Moco-chan!
The strongest what was that?
The strongest bone!
So you know, with all of your heart, no thinking too hard about it.
We definitely don't bite.
I said it, so you have to vote now, okay?
FUWAMOCO, you know, we have big tails, right?
We do!
Fluffy!
Yes!
Which tail's the strongest?
Mococo, right?
So Ruffians, make sure you vote for us, okay?
It's very very important, okay?
Not frivolous at all.
No, a bang for honor!
For honor, yes!
Vote it!
You can find it on Subaru-senpai's Twitter!
There's a questionnaire form.
I think it's the Google questionnaire form.
Yeah, probably Google.
Oi, it's a very cute song.
Hopefully you know you can head over to Subaru South by sweater.
And click the link to the questionnaire.
You know what to fill out, right?
Follow your heart, don't think too much.
BAU BAU!
As you know, Ruffians.
Well, I know a lot of Ruffians have been sending us wonderful photos of their trips, you know, and their days, their walks.
But, you're curious, you know?
FUWAMOCO, did you get to go see the cherry blossoms?
Did you get to do hanami?
Because just recently, it was hanami season!
It was hanami season!
Yeah, and, um, well, we really really wish that we could say that they're still here, that hanami season continues!
I'm gonna stick around now.
It's over.
Yeah.
But!
Actually!
We did get to do hanami!
Our very first hanami!
You know, it's a little bit complicated, but this is our very first proper hanami!
And you know, FUWAMOCO, this is our first spring with Abyssband in Japan!
I thought, but... Every single time!
FUWAMOCO Hi!
I just totally missed them.
You know every time Hanami season kind of rolls around, I feel a little bit like a tinge that maybe it'll end in lonely feelings again.
What!
This year!
Actually!
That changed!
Everything changed!
Yeah!
It changed!
Because!
We are invited to Hanami by Suisei-san!
Bye!
We are so so happy!
We are getting a bit emotional looking at all the beautiful sakura, the cherry blossoms.
Yeah!
I know!
But, you know, we went on a special boat together with her and a bunch of us and fun.
We had yummy food and got to chat about a bunch of different things.
Lots of laughing.
We silly all together.
Yeah, we put the series up by being extra silly.
Romantic!
Romantic fun.
It was a bit romantic.
Yeah, we got to chat a lot, you know, together.
Aki-senpai.
Mami-senpai.
Nene-chi.
Shion-senpai.
Much.
Yeah, you know.
And Moco-chan.
You stopped next to Rui-ne-senpai.
But you know, she even poured his tea in.
I felt bad.
I was like, ah, no, I don't care!
But then she went to go get his refills, too.
And I went to go rock them flowers, too.
And then the A.S.M.P.I.
would laugh.
They would rock quite a bit.
I was like, ah!
And then he would grip on the thing, and then the A.S.M.P.I.
would just be like.
That's the A.S.M.P.I.!
That was what she was like.
And then we asked her if it was fun when she lost money betting on Hoi Swing King and she was like... She seeped a little bit.
What was that?
I'm glad you're bringing this up.
Hot.
Yeah.
And Kanon, it was super cute laughing a lot together with us too!
Yeah, really.
It was really hot.
But you know, we're able to learn a lot from our senpai, you know, and it was just a really extra special experience for us.
Yeah!
And of course, the sakura, they're so beautiful!
So pretty!
It was really nice.
BAU BAU!
You know, no more lonely feelings.
Make it an annual thing.
That would be nice too.
Hanami Otero-sama.
No thank you.
No, Ruffians, you can do it.
We'll do that.
I wouldn't wish that on the Ruffians.
I'd like to do that together.
BAU BAU!
Wow, there's also something extra silly that we noticed.
Something on our mind a bit, huh?
Yeah, you know.
Wow, we saw on Twitter that there's a very popular picture going around.
I don't know.
I feel very complicated when I look at this.
Hi.
Let's share.
Well, let's take a look.
There's been a little bit of a upon the trap set.
Look here!
It's a train station!
What's going on here?
Look at the pon-de-rings, you know?
I don't know, when I look at this I'm like, we're being targeted, you know?
This is specifically for FUWAMOCO, hai!
Nobody just loses pon-de-rings like that!
Don't put them on the ground!
Right!
Don't put them on the ground, but if you do then I'll go get them.
You know if you get a large amount, which this is quite a large amount, you get a box.
And if you don't get a legend mount, then you get a very sturdy bag.
You know, so I'm thinking that this is targeted.
And somebody said it drops for FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMOCO no tame no hane desho kore!
Yeah, right.
They should have put them on napkins.
Yeah, at the very least, you know.
At the very least, that would be polite, you know.
5 seconds, I have a feeling that maybe it was a little bit longer than 5 seconds.
I'm glad though.
What did I have, what?
I'm not seeing anything.
Well, let's hope Justin doesn't think about it too much, huh?
More than what happened, not thought of this yet.
No ideas, don't think about it, don't look at it, Justin, don't!
Okay!
I didn't see anything.
Don't look at the meme.
Don't have them, okay?
Pause, okay?
Yeah.
Got it.
But, um... I'm surprised I haven't thought of this.
Yeah.
I'm very hungry looking at this.
I will follow that, wherever it leads.
With all my heart.
BAU BAU!
10 hour rule!
Really a pon-de-ring!
Pon-de-ring is the most delicious within the first 48 hours.
It's also exposed to, you know, the elements, the maybe, maybe 12 hours.
And then after that it's a little bit questionable, but you know it's a pon-de-ring so you really could
Let's get up upon the xylophone and take a look at the Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... Monika!
Monika!
BAU BAU!
Monika, that's such a silly sleepy face.
I love it.
Hi!
Monika is apparently the potato breed of dog.
Potato breed.
Do you like dog breed Ruffians, you know?
Shiba Inu, the roscoyki, the potato.
Yeah, the potato.
The cute potato!
Sleepy potato.
Yeah!
Potato breathing.
That's Monika.
This is Monika potato.
Yeah.
Cuddled potato.
Yes.
Very cute.
How does Monika BAU BAU Moco-chan?
I still don't think it's a...
I think we can see it in the photo here.
Monika's very sleepy still.
But it's time to wake up Monika!
Wake up!
BAU BAU!
Oh, that cute little nose.
Ah, where's the potato tummy?
Potato tummy?
Yeah.
Okay, I'll take the nose, you take the tummy.
Oh, potato tummy tickles.
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Hello Ruffians!
As you can see, things are starting to get a little bit warmer as we get deeper into the spring season.
Yeah, it rocks!
So, let's take a look where you've been going on walks on today I Let Anna Walk.
We have the dance!
Oh my gosh!
Beautiful sakura!
I wonder how heavy.
It looks so heavy!
This must be a legendary sakura tree if it's over a thousand years old.
Is it named Takizakura?
It looks delicious.
Or maybe it's just the type of the tree.
I think this tree is definitely amazing enough to deserve its own name, no?
I'm Takizakura-san!
Sanzuke.
Takizakura-sama.
Asama.
Nami-sama.
BAU BAU!
It was an amazing time just gazing at the beautiful cherry blossoms here and enjoying an ice tea!
We're glad that you were able to enjoy the coming of spring!
BAU BAU!
So pretty!
Mococo colors!
Moco-chan season!
I could only ever hope to be as magnificent as that tree, huh?
Yeah, this is like, uh, wow.
Yeah, at least ten generations?
Wow!
I'm not that old yet.
What does that mean Moco-chan?
That means what it means!
I'm not that old yet.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
And next we have our Question of the Day!
Today's Question of the Day is...
Hey FUWAMOCO!
Lately I'm starting to think that I'm losing my passion for this thing that I love, but I still don't want to just leave it.
Have you also encountered the same?
If so, I would like to know how did you guys deal with it?
BAU BAU!
It's okay, you know.
We totally understand this feeling.
I'd say it kinda might be hard to believe, but we've felt this feeling this way too before.
And you know, we got really deep and focused on our demon dog training before.
And you know...
We actually started to become a little bit distant toward the things that we like, you know, like anime and games.
It's hard to believe, right?
It's hard to believe!
It happens.
It happened and you know, it even got to the point that maybe you know we thought
You know, all the special things that you really love.
But you know, it turned out that sometimes you just have ups and downs, ebbs and flows, and that's natural.
You know, maybe sometime a way to focus on other things, maybe that's necessary.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
Maybe sometimes you just need a little time, and that's okay.
A strong passion, it can't burn strongly forever, you know?
It can't just be the same.
Sometimes it might weaken, the fire goes up, it goes down.
Maybe it burns even harder, maybe not.
But you never know, okay?
So just enjoy life!
Enjoy what makes you happy!
Okay?
Don't sweat it too much.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, thank you so much for all your submissions!
We've been getting so many wonderful, wonderful submissions with the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
We're looking for more doggy in the day questions!
Your walks, Ruffians, right now is the time to enjoy a very good walk!
And any Pero sightings too, so...
Please share with us the hashtag!
BAU BAU!
We have another stream coming up soon!
Soon, next, we're gonna be going out for a bit of a recording day!
Yeah, we should fly!
We're gonna do our best, we're really excited!
But!
After that, we'll be back for FUWAMOCO Morning on Wednesday!
What kind of troubles are we gonna get ourselves into between then, huh?
Nothing!
So, we'll do our best, Ruffians, and you do your best too, okay?
Can we take a peek at our schedule too?
After FUWAMOCO Morning, on Wednesday in the evening, we'll be playing Donkey Kong Country 2!
We will not be screaming.
Yeah, it'll be a crazy time because last time we had a bit of a struggle defeating the boss, but we beat him!
Yes!
And now, with the mic courts.
Yeah.
Mic courts.
Uh oh.
You better see what happens when we get on the Minecraft Ruffians.
But then we can forget all about it because it's Biboo's birthday party!
It's actually today.
So that means you gotta go say happy birthday to Biboo because today is the day that she was born.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
And we'll be back with more FUWAMOCO Mornings and maybe some suggestions.
Suggestions?
Stories?
Lots of stories.
BAU BAU!
And for those of you joining us in the archive today, your FUWAMOCO word is... It's BAU BAU Hanabi!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Abonboken!
BAU BAU!
Shion!
Waiwai!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
Mr. Alert.
4X.
FUWAMOCO!
Kamorus.
Ota.
FUWAMOCO!
Little Horn.
Booklet Painting.
FUWAMOCO!
Miguel Islands.
Vexor.
FUWAMOCO!
Piece of Zero.
This is today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!